a mammogram procedure uses low-dose
x-rays to view and detect changes in
breast tissue a woman's breasts are
composed of glandular tissue and ducts
fat connective tissue and blood vessels
a mammogram is a routine x-ray screening
test for women over the age of 40 or for
those with breast related symptoms such
as a lump or nipple discharge
before your mammogram make sure that
your breasts and underarms are clean and
do not wear deodorant since it may
appear on mammogram x-rays as calcium
spots a screening mammogram is performed
yearly as a routine study for women over
40 when there are no symptoms related to
the breast a technician will begin by
placing one of your breasts between two
specialized plates the plates will
compress to flatten your breasts so that
the camera can get clearer pictures of
your breast tissue you may feel some
discomfort during the compression but it
will only last a few seconds then you
will change position for a second
picture which will be taken from the
side
this procedure will then be repeated on
your other breast you will get the
results from your screening mammogram
later usually within a couple of weeks a
diagnostic mammogram is performed if a
screening mammogram shows an abnormality
or if there are symptoms such as a
breast lump or nipple discharge during a
diagnostic mammogram x-ray images are
taken from different views and an
ultrasound may be performed you will get
the results from your diagnostic
mammogram during your visit to determine
the next steps